hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
president trump reviving daily
coronavirus press briefings as the u.s
surpasses four million recorded cases
of covid19 fox news sunday host chris
wallace
discusses why he thinks the
commander-in-chief has changed his tone
on the virus and face masks
he also gives his thoughts on the 2020
election and his recent interview with
the president
and the trump administration ordering
china to close its consulate in houston
citing concerns over the nation stealing
american intellectual property
texas congressman dan crenshaw weighs in
on the escalating tensions between the
two countries
and the possibility of presumptive
democratic nominee joe biden
winning the lone star state in november
plus commentary from fox nation host
tammy bruce the fox news rundown is a
daily news podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe on
your favorite podcast player
by going to foxnewspodcast.com i'm
ainsley earhart i'm brett baer i'm katie
pavlich and this
is the fox news rundown
friday july 24th 2020 i'm chris foster
president trump's back at coronavirus
briefings and fox news sunday host chris
wallace says about where we are now
i don't care how big biden's lead is
right now
and it appears according to the polls to
be somewhere between 8 and 15 points
this race is still very much up for
grabs
i'm jessica rosenthal the virus federal
law enforcement in u.s cities
the election and new tensions with china
texas congressman dan crenshaw weighs in
on it all the chinese are not good
actors
they haven't been for a long time and
america and the world are really just
now waking up to that
and i'm tammy bruce i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
a week ago today president trump was
sitting down to tape an interview with
fox news sunday host chris wallace
saying about the coronavirus outbreak
we'll put out the flames and we'll put
out in some cases just
burning embers we also have burning
embers we have embers
and we do have flames just since then
more than 5 000 americans have died with
covet 19 and
cases are up in more states than not
with more states adding mask mandates
president trump is now talking up the
use of masks even
putting out a picture of himself in one
and he's back holding what he says will
be regular coronavirus briefings at the
white house
i just spoke to dr fauci uh dr burks is
right outside and they're giving me all
of
everything they know as of as of this
point in time and
i'm giving the information to you and i
think it's probably a
very uh concise way of doing it it seems
to be working out very well
a conversation recorded for joe biden's
campaign former president obama says
about
this administration's coronavirus
response compared to a biden
administration
why i have so much confidence that
you're going to be able to deal with
uh kovit in the way that other countries
with all kinds of resources or dealing
with it right now which is smartly
i have confidence that you're going to
actually listen to the experts yeah
and you're going to pay attention to the
science
and you're not going to
quit president trump though is making
coronavirus more of a focus again
he seems to have decided that
politically and
also in terms of policy he needs to he
can't run away from this he's got to
confront it
fox news sunday host chris wallace we're
in a really bad situation
right now we're i've seen double the
number of cases every day that we saw at
the height in april when we thought it
was
you know terrible and you know after
seeing
it go down to about two or three hundred
deaths a day which is terrible it's like
a jumbo airliner crashing every day
we're back up now to a thousand and i
was
struck that he seemed so
unwilling to acknowledge and and and
engage in
that and now you're seeing him having
done so so it's it's a pretty dramatic
turnaround
uh some people have called it a reset
some people in an about face but
i think it's smart in terms of policy i
think it's smart in terms of politics
it's funny you mentioned jumbo jet i saw
a tweet the other day who was i
i don't know who it was but um said oh
my god did you see the two jumbo jane uh
jets crashed over st
louis all these people died oh wait no
that's just coronavirus i guess it's not
a big deal without the planes
uh it's just it's a staggering number of
people dying of this day after day after
well that's right and you know if we if
we had a
i probably shouldn't put those out in
the universe but if you had a
terrible plane crash and three or
whatever 100 people
we would you know we would or a natural
or a fire or something we'd all be
sitting there saying oh my
how horrible it is and we kind of have
begun to accept
two or three hundred or 400 people dying
in a day as
well that's you know not so bad as it
used to be it's terrible
it isn't as bad as it was at the height
when over 2000 were dying
but but it's pretty bad and now we're
back over a thousand yesterday
yeah um president trump as as he has all
along says that he's the law order
president he campaigned on it he's
uh now with these federal troops in
portland oregon he said he's going to do
it in other cities too
now our friend judge andrew napolitano
on fox is among those saying that this
is completely illegal federal troops
making arrests like this but president
trump says
if mayors and governors won't protect
cities i will
um talk about that and also does joe
biden pay a price
for videos of fires and vandalism well
um
in terms i'm not gonna i haven't studied
this as much as the judge and he's the
judge i'm not
but in the particular case of portland
where
uh the protesters are attacking federal
buildings
i think there's a legal argument to be
made that it's
it is proper for the the federal
agents in this case dhs their their ice
agents their
uh border patrol agents to defend and to
make arrests so i i'm not sure that it
is illegal to do that
and but what we're talking about in
cities like
chicago and kansas city are not attacks
on federal property
it's street crime and that's a different
question and
interestingly enough after all the
president's talk about work if they
can't
control the cities we're going to go in
it doesn't seem like they're going to be
putting
these agents out on the street as as
policemen
uh they're basically saying that they're
going to be there
and folding into joint task forces
between the city authority city police
and federal authorities
that are working on gangs and gun
violence and things like that and
they'll be doing
you know police investigations uh
not not and you know you couldn't you
couldn't do what you're doing in
portland in a city like chicago you
can't
mass uh police on the streets it's a
it's a city of several million
but you know what neighborhood are you
gonna go into it it's not like
uh you're gonna know where the the gang
violence is gonna be this
this today as opposed to yesterday so
it strikes me that that kind of uh
infrastructure
uh reinforcement by the police and
interestingly enough
mayor lightfoot of chicago who is very
opposed to a kind of portland model
seems just fine with it if it's if it's
just an increase
in sort of joint task forces
to fight crime in the streets uh schools
continue to be one of the more complex
things about this coronal coronavirus
getting back to that
i read a poll eight percent of americans
want a full reopening
um despite the president's threat to
defund schools that don't fully reopen
that's obviously being norton a lot of
districts this is just it's such a huge
health and economic issue schools
encompass
everything that's a that's that's hard
about this problem
absolutely uh because first of all
you've got the kids and who could you be
more protective of than the kids it
appears
from some studies that have been done
the kids don't get the virus
as much as older people do but some
still get terribly sick
and while there was a study i think it
was in south korea that between
zero and nine or ten uh kids don't
transmit
the virus as much as older people do or
really much at all that between 10 and
17 or 18 they transmit it
at least as much as adults and perhaps
even more so
so you know look we don't know the
science in this thing at all and i
understand people being
very concerned and then you know
obviously
it's the question of if peop if kids
transmit it to each other
then what are they doing to the teachers
in the school or the
custodial staff in the school and what
are they doing when they get home
now you brought and then add to that the
economic question which is
if i'm staying home to take care of my
kids thank god all my kids are out of
college and all grown
uh you know i can't go back to work so
you know it has huge
uh impact in terms of health huge impact
in terms of the economy and
school districts are going to have to
decide this uh on the fly
it's somewhat in the dark because we
really don't know
what it's going to be like if you start
sending kids back to school on anything
close to a full-time basis
and you have 20 25 kids in a class uh
joe biden's doing this or has done by
now this
this sit-down conversation with barack
obama
talking to barack obama isn't talking to
chris wallace um
now can he get elected by at least so
far kind of ducking and just being
obama adjacent uh i i think he's doing
just fine right now and i saw
what they had put out yesterday you know
we're doing clips of
biden and and obama and they're socially
distanced they seem like they're about
15
20 feet apart and yeah i got to say is
he's become an ex-president by
obama rather has become very cool you
know he's got the
the really quite white gray or white
hair
and he's wearing black shirts and things
like that i mean
he's he's a cool dude uh and you know i
did
for the people that like obama uh you
know i think that there's
some reflected glory and and to see the
two of them together
it was kind of cool is that work in july
yeah
does that work after the convention i
don't think so i think he's gotta
find a way even in this new reality he's
not going to hold
huge rallies with his packed auditoriums
but he's got to find a way to get out
he's got to take questions he's going to
have to do the debates
um you know the the basement strategy is
not going to work
from now till november this sunday it's
a hundred days till the election on the
one hand
that seems like a blink on the other
hand you know every news cycle here is
an eternity
a hundred days i don't care how big
biden's lead is right now and it appears
according to the polls to be somewhere
between
8 and 15 points this race
is still very much up for grabs and very
winnable by donald trump depending on
what happens
over those hundred days uh finally you
see the numbers on your trump interview
i
don't know how how into that kind of
thing you are if you just put your head
down and do the job or if you actually
look at ratings but have you looked
yeah i know of course i did yeah we got
we've got
almost 6 million people between the
original play and the
and the replay and that's you know the
biggest number we've gotten in a long
time and
we were up 50 over the previous week and
and last year and
you know it's it's people want to see
donald trump you know he's he is i i
happen to think he's overexposed i think
he does too many interviews but
particularly one like this that
was different and special and got a lot
of feedback
uh you know as as they say in field of
dreams if you build it they will come
well we've also got five million views
on that interview just on youtube alone
now by the way
i'm really oh so we're up in in double
digit millions wow
congratulations thank you well i think
i think i think that the president had
something to do with that i mean of
course he did people want to see the
president but i think they also want to
see
somebody bring something out of him that
maybe some others haven't so far
chris wallace let me just say here's the
dirty little secret and you know it well
from being in this business so you bask
in glory for
a few hours and then the thought is well
now who am i going to book this week
you know i'm struggling to find people
tv
is relentless whether if you're doing a
daily show it's 24 hours later if it's a
weekly show it's one week later
how do i feed the beast so uh and and
we'll have good guests or obviously good
subjects
uh is it going to be another trump
interview unfortunately not but i'm
hoping for a biden interview sooner
rather than later
i bet you'll get it how can you not at
some point
we'll see hope so all right fox news
sunday host chris wallace chris thanks
you bet thank you chris
this is tammy bruce with your fox news
commentary coming up
tensions with china are increasing here
in the u.s
this week the assistant attorney general
for national security
john demers announced charges against
two chinese spies
who'd been hacking into businesses not
just here in the u.s but
all over the world for a decade stealing
or trying to steal
hundreds of millions of dollars worth of
security data and intellectual
property he said while they sometimes
operated on their own behalf
they also did work for the chinese
government unsurprisingly
the intrusions targeted industries
outlined in the made in china
2025 plan china's 10-year plan for
targeting strategic advanced
technology manufacturing industries for
development
while the plan calls for an
innovation-driven approach cases like
this one
show it is as much a road map to theft
as it is a guide to innovation
he says they also notably targeted
companies working on covet 19 vaccine
research
also this week the state department told
the chinese consulate in houston texas
to close down
saying it was directed to close in order
to protect american i.p
and americans private information china
promised to retaliate
and secretary of state mike pompeo
called that location a hub
of spying and intellectual property
theft
also this week court documents revealed
a chinese biology researcher
is believed to be hiding at the chinese
consulate in san francisco
the fbi says they interviewed her in
june about lying on her visa application
after they saw pictures of her online in
a chinese military uniform
three others have been charged with visa
fraud suspected of lying about their
status as members of the people's
liberation army
the armed forces of the chinese military
what we know is that the chinese have
even have used consulates like this one
and this might have
been their primary hub to engage in
intellectual property theft
hacking influence operations all of the
above
dan crenshaw is a republican and
congressman from the houston texas area
good for the state department for for
taking action so the burning of
documents is what occurs after
the fact uh once you decide to close um
an embassy or a consulate like that
uh they're gonna burn all the evidence
and that's exactly what they did
um you know it's it's pretty obviously
that they're not innocent in all this
uh again we're seeing something similar
play out in in san francisco
um right now as well no consulate there
so
the chinese are not good actors they
they haven't been for a long time and
america and the world are really just
now waking up to that you know well over
a decade
of hoping for the best when it comes to
chinese relations and their behavior on
the world stage
and we need to wake up to it we need to
realize that
they do not have the same values as as
most people across the world they don't
have the same values of freedom
and respect for human rights democracy
free trade they're acting
completely irresponsibly and against all
the values we hold dear
yeah but but to we still have to work
with them right i mean they own
a lot of our debt we make a lot of a lot
of our companies are based in china i
mean
what what is the future of a
relationship with china look like it
sounds like a fine line needs to be
walked here it does but
you know we need to be encouraging
companies to diversify their investments
to it to a huge extent
um it's it should be well known to to
companies knowing now that it's
extremely risky to do business in china
they basically force you to give up your
intellectual property when you
when you do so um the the the point is
is that we can't be
we can't continue to be pushed beyond
our limits and i think we've let that
happen for too long
uh the president trump ran on this when
he was elected in 2016 and
and and the situation hasn't really um
you know the situation has come to light
um i think in a much bigger way since
then so
of course the right head is difficult
but acquiescences cannot be on the table
now just as it seemed tensions might
ease last year
with china after phase one of a trade
deal tensions ramped back up
with kova 19 which the president calls
the china virus
as cases surge in parts of the country
including florida
president trump said thursday he is
canceling the jacksonville portion
of the republican national convention
the timing for this event is not right
just not right with what's happened
recently
the flare-up in florida to have a big
convention
it's not the right time it's
really something that for me i have to
protect the american people
telerallies and a convention speech will
still happen just
not in a crowded convention setting
earlier this week the president told fox
news medical contributor dr mark siegel
that most of the closures and shutdowns
due to the virus in cities and states
have been
political i really believe the democrats
are doing this for a political reason if
you close down california you know it's
a big state you close down some of these
places
it's not going to show watch on november
4th everything will open up
congressman crenshaw wouldn't say all
shutdowns were pure politics
i can't read their minds i but i but i
can't say that their judgment is off
and i i don't i i think when you when
you make the decision to shut down
you're jumping ahead past about a
thousand
intermediate steps and solutions and
jumping to the most extreme possible
and costly as possible option there is
to slow the spread of a virus
and it's it's based on this thinking
that the virus can be stopped at all
now it can't it can be slowed down and
the reason we we desired to slow it down
in the first place for that 15 days to
slow the spread
was to make sure that we had hospital
and ppe capacity to
to deal with it we've reached that
capacity
there's nobody in america that hasn't
gotten the care they've needed
it doesn't mean that the hospital
systems aren't strained they are
in many places in houston in particular
you know our hospitalization growth has
been negative
for almost a week now and that's good
news and uh that that trend appears to
continue it wasn't it's
we shouldn't be surprised by a giant
spike after massive protests and
and holiday gatherings um and reopenings
well maybe but but does that really make
sense using deductive logic
so texas reopened in you know around may
1st and you know i was there i
see people out all the time we didn't
get spikes until
until the that week following late may
and again there's a layering effect of
of um you know people gathering in
social and social mechanisms you know
social bars and
and holiday gatherings and 60 000 people
in the street breathing on each other in
close proximity
so if you look at california l.a county
has almost basically the same number of
deaths as the entire state of texas
la county never really opened okay so
what what
so sorry but no that there's there's
actually and studies would show
that targeted targeted lockdowns meaning
cancel big events cancel
can't you know close down bars has about
the same outcome on the curve
as universal lockdowns but what's extra
about universal lockdowns you're adding
cost upon cost upon cost and these
leaders
you know that that that that jump to
this conclusion of universal lockdowns
pretend like those costs don't exist
well they do exist
you know costing the economy is cost to
lives
cost of the economy means increased
domestic abuse it means people not going
to the hospitals because
the media is telling them that they
should be too scared to go in the
hospitals because the
hospitals are overwhelmed and that's not
true but what happens is people die at
home because they're too afraid to go
into the hospital because
lead so-called leaders are
fear-mongering you have to tell people
the truth
and so i'm sorry but when you actually
logically look at this
that that is that is not what caused
spikes it should be obvious to everybody
what caused
spikes and now we're dealing with that
and what we're seeing is and
and at least in texas that's the
hospitalizations of have plateaued
in in houston specifically they're
negative growth
um the president this week expanded uh
operation legend
in sending federal law enforcement
agents into cities that are experiencing
a spike recently in violent crime
i'm wondering how necessary do you feel
this is you know crime
goes up and down depending on you know
times of year even
are you of the mindset that in the few
cities that are
experiencing a surge in a you know a few
dozen to a couple hundred federal law
enforcement agents that that's really
necessary right now
i don't know i kind of chuckled the way
you the way you put that
um yeah crime does surge and goes up and
down across cities but that's
that's obviously not what we're seeing
right now
you know i mean you're seeing you're
seeing uh you know like something like a
200 increase in shootings in new york
city
you're seeing six weeks of of violent
mobs in portland uh you know and this is
after these cities have actually
defunded their police there
uh mayor of portland took away 15
million dollars from the police bureau
you're seeing looting you're seeing
chaos you're seeing them try to burn
down uh federal property and so federal
property under you know
the president has under law they have to
protect that
you know you know so so the question is
do they
do they shirk that duty or do they not
well portland isn't part of operation
legend right it's kansas city chicago
and albuquerque right now
okay so i'm not i'm not sure the federal
federal agents
there's federal property in in all of
these i mean do we want to live in a
world where we accept
crime after crime after crime until
communities are
are so unstable and so unsafe to live
that nobody wants to invest there nobody
wants to live there
you know where do we draw the line are
we a society of law and order or
not and this is the fundamental question
and and i i i find it really impressive
that so many have been able to twist
that narrative back
on on federal law enforcement demonize
federal law enforcement as
stormtroopers claim that they're
unmarked police that it's all of this is
nonsense it's completely untrue it's
flat out lies
they're very clearly marked and and if
anything they're
they're engaging um you know a lot of
these writers in the most strategic way
possible instead of instead of
confronting them like a line of
you know line of uh rioters with with
shield and all this they're they're
they're picking
they're picking out individual violent
people one at a time
and it's effective these are not
peaceful protesters
you know again the the real question is
do we actually defend a sense of law and
order or do we not
and if you don't believe that we should
then then i wonder what the next step is
and i wonder how
i wonder how slippery that slope is and
i don't think anybody wants to live in
those kind of cities
um finally i just want to ask you about
polling i know um
there's a lot of questions about the
polling data we've seen i know the trump
administration
and the trump campaign says a lot of it
is not to be believed but nevertheless
some of it does show that the former
vice president
joe biden is more competitive in texas
we've heard uh from senator ted cruz
that the closeness of the numbers in
texas
it's not race he says as some want to
say he says it's socioeconomic
that the middle class and suburban women
are moving away from president trump
specifically in georgia and texas um as
a texas congressman is there any truth
to that in your mind
yeah i mean the polling is real it's
been that way for a while it even
predated the the
covet era um you know and so you know
the president needs to to deliver a
strong message here and
um and and persuade these
who are generally center-right voters if
you really talk to them
you know what do they want for their
communities what do they want from their
government
they're going to be center-right voters
but yeah they're they're turned off by
the president and so
it's incumbent on him to explain that
listen joe biden is not necessarily a
do-nothing president he's going to bring
in a very radical agenda
and what does that mean for a place like
texas well we already know that the
democrat agenda
is divert funding from funding from the
police um
it's it's it's whitewashed the the
violent mobs and
and make excuses for them okay so you're
going to see more of this kind of thing
i don't know why you'd want to appease
um the mob like this you're going to see
a coordinated attack on america's energy
infrastructure
all right you're going to see you're
going to see the refusal to build
natural gas pipelines which by the way
have been
are the leading cause of reduced
emissions in america
you're going to see that you're going to
see less job growth you're going to see
an economic plan
that doubles that increases your taxes
possibly doubles the corporate tax rate
is what biden has said and makes it
harder to hire and harder to create your
business
okay you're going to see a coordinated
attack on your private health care biden
is going to double down
on the big lie that you can if you like
your doctor you can keep it now he wants
a public option
and so there's a lot of real
consequences to voting for biden this is
what i tell people even if you like the
guy
better than trump there's a real radical
agenda here that that is
that they're not even trying to hide
anymore republicans have long said
this is what they believe and people
sort of looked past it because they
didn't see it they
you know they haven't seen the radical
agenda from democrats that they've that
they've put toward forth in the house
they haven't seen that become law so
it's never had any effect on people
but this is the agenda and it's all of
those things i just said and it's
it's it's anti-growth it's going to be
less jobs and it's going to be very
harmful to our communities
well congressman dan crenshaw thank you
so much for your time
hey thanks for having me
getting schooled is a podcast hosted by
fox nation's abby hornacek each week
abby and her expert guests tackle topics
we take for granted and help explain the
roots and meanings behind them subscribe
and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
america is listening to fox news read
and review the fox news rundown on apple
podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
katie taylor was out of work for three
months and recently returned to her job
at the pub
in granger indiana she's a server there
and she says she loves it
she told wndu that she's also a recent
graduate of indiana university south
bend studying education i had just
finished my student teaching when
everything kind of shut down katie was
back at work when heather hotrum
another server from a restaurant in
michigan randomly decided to stop into
the pub for dinner
the bill was only 35 bucks but the tip
was a lot more than usual
so i asked for donations and then we
decided to come up to dinner
[Music]
yep 330 dollars katie began to cry as
heather counted out the money
what's happening and she was like so
we've been you know getting donations
and
we've just decided to bless you it was
part of the venmo challenge which is a
social media trend that challenges
people to raise money then use it to
leave generous tips for their wait staff
i was just in awe just completely in
shock
the first thing that came to mind was
awesome i get to buy
new shoes for work because that was what
i said
perfect new shoes i've been looking for
like a week i'm like
oh my gosh a hundred dollars for shoes
that's hard to
hard to deal with katie says she plans
to help others who are struggling
the most understanding the kindest most
generous person you can be because
everyone is struggling
and if you're in the position to pay it
forward if you're in the position to
help others
don't hesitate to do that tanya j powers
fox news
it's time for your fox news commentary
tammy bruce
what's on your mind after an effort by
the legacy media to disappear the story
the nation is finally hearing about the
mayhem and violence overtaking portland
oregon for almost two months the city
has been in the grip of the typical
vandalism chaos and bedlam
that is the hallmark of the fascist
group antifa a federally declared
terrorist group
they along with the democratic-aligned
marxist group black lives matter
have made portland a hellscape for the
law-abiding citizens who live there
this story is now only being covered
because president trump realized
local democratic leadership had no real
interest in ending the chaos and sent
in federal law enforcement to establish
the law and order
every american wants and deserves but in
today's upside down world
the federal government coming to the aid
of a city under siege
has enraged democratic leadership that
alone should tell you everything you
need to know about that party and its
malevolent politics
but it's the reaction and comment of
house speaker nancy pelosi
that has proven the most revealing and
shocking about the attitude
of the perfunctory leader of that party
responding to these events mrs pelosi
tweeted
unidentified stormtroopers unmarked cars
kidnapping protesters and causing severe
injuries in response to graffiti
these are not the actions of a
democratic republic the department of
homeland security's actions in portland
undermine its mission trump and his
storm troopers must be stopped
beyond the fact that much of what she
said there is not true
exactly who are these people mrs pelosi
is casting
as the same as hitler's most notorious
and murderous terrorist organization
they are fellow americans who dared to
make a commitment to this country
by joining law enforcement they are our
brothers sisters husbands wives and best
friends
they are our neighbors yet mrs pelosi
with a grotesque excitement
easily declared them nazis and
kidnappers
she would not have said this as a lark
everything she and the democrats do is
contemplated assessed and then
implemented
the smearing of americans in law
enforcement is something they decided
was a good thing to do speaking to the
press
the president also made clear he has no
intention of allowing other great
american cities
to become victim of either frightened
incompetent or malevolent democratic
leadership
additionally he tweeted we're not going
to let new york and chicago and
philadelphia and detroit and baltimore
in all of these
oakland is a mess we're not going to let
this happen in our country
all run by liberal democrats after mr
trump's comments the chicago tribune
reported that the city
will see the deployment of federal
agents in light of the slaughter
inflicted
upon chicagoans every weekend
the wall street journal reports that
shootings in new york
have increased in the city by 66.8
percent from the start of the year
with the number of shooting victims up
77.5 percent
yet the mayor bill de blasio is now
threatening to sue to stop dhs from
sending federal agents
to new york to help stem that bloodbath
democratic leadership
calls federal law enforcement
stormtroopers as local leadership fights
against assistance
to stop murderous crime waves killing
their cities
the rhetoric against police continues
and police budgets are getting cut
as in new york or certain crime units
have already been disbanded
democrats revel in anarchy and mayhem
and throwing your family
into the volcano is the price they
decided
is worth paying as they imagine making
mr trump
look bad this is tammy bruce
[Music]
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
[Music]
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion
you trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes